[Music]
coming up on fyi what should we do if a
story in the news upsets us
[Music]
and what do liam payne mo farah and eva
ably from britain's got talent all have
in common they're all on this week's fyi
[Music]
welcome to fyi the only new show where
people our age get to investigate their
big stories and how they affect us fyi
is where you get your say and all the
latest info from us so let's start off
with a warning from charities about the
three c's and how they affect millions
of children
[Music]
so oxfam and save the children hit the
headlines saying the three seas conflict
coping 19 and climate change has led to
a massive shortage of food in east
africa what's called a famine
families are fleeing their homes from
fighting the pandemic also means that
many people are unable to farm the land
and distribute food and drought is
killing crops and when we head over to
asia children across india and
bangladesh have seen their homes and
schools destroyed by flooding from more
extreme weather because of climate
change
but we can all do something to help
check this out
this is the moment pupils from john
bramston primary school got a surprise
visit from singer liam payne and athlete
mo farah
[Applause]
so they're touring schools to spread the
word about the soccer aids school
challenge
the idea is to get us all to organise a
sponsored sport event at our schools to
raise money for the children's charity
unicef which with other charities helps
millions of children around the world
it's about being able to just engage
with kids and letting kids have fun and
take part in different you know games
and stuff and that's what we did we got
involved ourselves and it was just nice
to see the kids smiling and that are so
going get involved because that's what
it's all about
every kid out there in the world should
be able to you know go out there and
play him and smile it's such a big
nationwide thing they can all get
involved with all it takes is a ball and
a few obstacles you can make it up
yourself the creativity's there and once
again kids get to play whilst doing
something great so it's massively
important
liam and mo farah have teamed up with
loads of other stars to take on the
england team at the soccer aid footy
match on june 12th which since it
started has raised 60 million pounds
good job man
well sticking with football your team's
done all right yeah not too bad so
manchester city won the premier league
again we scored three in five minutes
which is incredible we took it down to
the wire but overall the premier league
is blue again well i'm not into football
but i think that's pretty amazing it was
it was pretty good the atmosphere was
incredible i mean what a game so we are
so here's a picture with me in the
premier league trophy looking it's got
the blue ribbons on of course
so we found a viral video that could be
fake or fact
this is the russian president vladimir
putin in a televised address to the
nation
it went viral because when translated he
announced the end of russia's invasion
of ukraine saying we've managed to reach
peace with ukraine
but sadly it's fake in fact social media
companies were quick to highlight it's a
deep fake these videos are created by
using digital technology to edit a false
mouth onto the face which matches the
words of an impersonator's voice
[Music]
still to come an fyi news club member
takes us into the world of immersive art
and we chat to the britain's got talent
act everyone is talking about eva ably
[Music]
the recent shooting at a school in
america will be something you'll have
heard about and of course it's really
upsetting
we all have a right to go to school and
not to have to worry about our safety
but at least 19 children and two
teachers lost their lives at the robb
elementary school in uvalde texas when
an 18 year old opened fire
this is one of many shootings in schools
and communities in america over the
years
and we did some research
america has a massive problem with gun
violence
that's because by law every american
over the age of 18 has the right to own
guns for sport and protection and there
aren't many background checks in place
to make sure they're a responsible adult
there are as many guns in america as
there are people and increasingly guns
are falling into the wrong hands
a lot of americans are calling for gun
control meaning more background checks
on people who want to buy a gun but
equally a lot of americans including
powerful politicians feel strongly about
the right to own a gun without too many
questions they are known as the gun
lobby
in reaction to the shooting in texas
this is what president biden had to say
why don't we keep letting this happen
where in god's name is our backbone
to have the courage to deal with and
stand up to the lobbies
it's highly unlikely that gun violence
would ever be a problem in the uk
because we have very strict controls
over who can own a gun and what it can
be used for
we've got hold of fyi psychologist
laverne for more advice hi laverne hi
there so when we do see news like this
that is really upsetting what do you
think the best ways are to try and get
through it well i think that it's really
important that everybody recognizes that
they're going to have a slightly
different response and that's okay but
if you have found it upsetting then i
think it's really important you do the
things that can be helpful so that might
be talking to adults so for example your
parents or your friends but really what
we want young people to do is to make
sure they take care of themselves and
one way to do that is to make sure you
get your news from a new source that you
really do trust so for example like fyi
and helps you understand the facts
so some of us go on holiday to america
or have friends and family there and are
feeling quite anxious you know when we
get a shot we have to think well is this
something that happens a lot and
actually in actual fact these things do
not happen as often as perhaps our
brains might make us feel and then i
think as you think sort of more slowly
through your responses then you can get
back to a place where you can sort of
trust your accuracy and think well
actually no going on holiday to america
is something i'm looking forward to i
don't need to be worried about this and
then in turn thinking about family and
friends there that actually are living
their lives very very well because these
events are not very common they're very
rare well that's really great advice
thank you so much for speaking to us
that's great nice to see you again
so brayden what are we gonna do about
these
i'm not sure what are we gonna do about
these well i mean it makes me so angry
to see how many airlines hand out water
in plastic bottles i mean on a british
airways flight it's like 250 passengers
i mean it's not the best option but they
can be recycled yeah but that's why i
like to use these when i go to the
airport when i go through security i
have it empty and then just before i
board the plane i fill it up with water
but i was confused why british airways
were still giving out plastic bottles of
mineral water so i wrote to them asking
why and their response was saying that
you know yeah they are guilty of still
using plastic bottles but they're trying
to move away from that so they're using
plastic bottles made of recycled
material
nice one scarlett now it's not just
downstairs to bring you guys stories and
fyi if you've got an issue that you want
to have a stay on then just let us know
even better set up an fyi news club at
your school members get the chance to
report for fyi make a film about their
own story we might even film it for you
and news club members can have their say
right here on fyi just get a teacher to
head to our webpage for more details so
braden have you ever been to an art
exhibition a ballet an opera or a
musical well i have been to a musical
don't mind the musical and i have been
to an art exhibition but i've never
really thought about an opera
well i love acting so i'll go for a
musical any day but how do you know if
you don't give it a go the pandemic
means loads of us missed out on school
trips to shows exhibits or museums so
for one week in june the channel sky
arts is providing loads of resources and
experiences for our teachers to help us
get out of the classroom and give art in
the performing arts a go it's called
access all arts week we sent fyi news
club member and keen artist ava to check
out the kind of thing you could be doing
here's her report from the uk's first
immersive digital art exhibition
[Music]
it's an art gallery that nothing i've
ever seen before
this is a 360 degree digital exhibition
you can step right into the art and
experience it in ways that you can't
with traditional galleries
it feels like i'm in space
i can't believe that computers have
imagined this it looks to me as if it's
hand designed by the artist himself
this exhibition is called machine
memoirs space
two million images of space taken by
nasa were fed into a computer which then
showed its own version of what it
imagined our universe to look like
and the artist rafique annadol chatted
to me about what inspired him to make a
digital exhibition what do you want
people to experience when they step into
your exhibition what do you want them to
feel so the piece here is an immersive
architectural experience that i feel
like people are stepping inside
an artwork and the artwork is all around
you
what made you want to look at outer
space i think as humanity space is one
of the most common excitements
for many of us
where are we going what is their life in
the space and ai clearly it's our future
and it's now we know that machines can
learn right but can a mission dream
i think this question is really very
exciting i think my friends would really
really love it because they just love
art and painting and drawing and i would
definitely recommend this to anyone of
all ages
nice one ava now everybody's been
talking about the 14 year old stand-up
comedian that wowed the judges on
britain's got talent eva ably take a
look at this
now before i start i would like to
apologize if you can't understand me
i got a disability called cerebral palsy
i'm
[Laughter]
eva revealed she has a disability called
cerebral palsy and she had a hard time
at school for seven years but she's
clearly come out on top
so there's nothing more we like here on
fyi than beating the bullies so we
invited eva into the studio hi there how
are you hi i'm good thank you how are
you i'm very well thank you so first of
all you was amazing on britain's got
talent you were so funny oh thank you no
no this is so true really you got
everybody laughing and did comedy maybe
help you overcome a tough time at school
yes so i find with my speech as soon as
i start to talk to some of my speech
would put people off and they would
avoid me so you
telling them a joke would break the ice
and they would start to get to know me
that's incredible i mean it takes so
much guts just to do stand-up comedy in
the first place and especially on
britain's got talent so how was that for
you honestly it was just amazing it was
my first
time ever on stage
and i just had
no time for nerves my excitement
took over
i know i'd be really nervous if i had to
do that you said that was your first
time on stage i mean you would never
think it you looked like a professor
first time ever and you had the judges
up on their feet and you had the public
in stitches as i say everybody was
laughing i mean how did it feel to get
that reaction it just felt because i've
had years and years of tough time at
school it felt nice for people to have a
good reaction to me and put a massive
smile on my face and i felt like i was
just being me i wasn't hiding away from
anyone
i just felt amazing everybody loved it
didn't they yeah
so what advice would you give to someone
who might be going through you know a
tough time with other people just be you
don't hide away and don't care about
what anyone thinks of here as long as
you're happy with yourself that's all
matters it's so amazing that you're
showing other people that might be a bit
different that they can do everything
that everyone else can do
really inspirational oh thank you guys
so much i wish you all the best and we
can't wait to see what you do in the
future thank you guys so much for being
amazing being here today thank you it's
been great talking to you so thank you
so much for your time
and if you want to find out more about
how to get some help if you are having a
tough time just head to our webpage at
first.news forward slash fyi
[Music]
so we're all gearing up for a long bank
holiday weekend to mark the queen 70
years on the throne the longest-serving
monarch ever exactly and finally we
leave you with messages for her majesty
from fyi news club members see you next
time for a write royal fyi bye
hello your majesty we would like to
congratulate you on your platform
i hope you enjoyed your time on the
throne they're very proud of you as our
queen
congratulations on your seventeenth
captive jubilee
i'm grateful for you because you're very
good at running the country even though
you don't totally run it boris johnson
does
[Music]
you